- Hello, Khan Academy students.
This is Brandi Chastain,
former U.S. Women's National Team member,
Olympic gold medalist
and World Cup champion.
And I'm here to say to you that
what you're doing is not easy.
Trying to learn in an adverse environment,
to be a champion takes
a lot of determination,
desire, resiliency, it
takes a lot of falling down
and getting back up
and I want you to know that anything
that is worthwhile is worth fighting for,
is worth getting dirty, it's
worth getting a couple scrapes.
And if it were easy,
everybody would be doing it
and it wouldn't be a big deal,
but what you're doing is a big deal.
You're challenging yourselves
to learn like champions,
and to be a champion takes
time, it's a process,
it's not always going to be smooth
and most of the time success
isn't this upward ascension,
straight line to gold medals.
So remember that what you're doing
is really a life's work
and a life's journey.
And when you get to be my age, (chuckles)
you'll understand that
maybe a little bit more,
but you can look back and
say, "I stuck with it,
it wasn't easy, sometimes
I wanted to give up".
I know that along my journey
to playing in the Olympics
and being on the World Cup team
and scoring that final penalty kick goal,
where I got to do a little celebrating,
it wasn't easy.
I was on the team, cut from the team.
I made the team in a different position
which I'd never played before.
And when that was presented
to me, I had a choice.
Did I wanna be on the team
and try to make a contribution
to a positive outcome,
or was I more prideful and say,
"No, that's not my position,
I wanna play my position".
And I realized that being on the team
and having a chance to get
into the game was really what I wanted.
So I want you to remember
that when things just
get tough, you got this.
You got to remember, you
are talented, you're smart.
We all have a competitor inside of us
and you have to be willing to allow it
to come out and don't
settle, never settle.
Becoming a gold medalist is
definitely not about settling,
and you in 2021, we'll be champions.
So I'm going to hopefully give you
your first gold medal ever.
So if you bow your head,
here comes the gold medal.
There it is.
You are now on team
Brandi and we are strong
and we are resilient
and we get the job done.
So all the best to you in 2021.
Hopefully at some point
we'll meet on a soccer field
or somewhere else near you.
Take care.